oh oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
etc
[Musique]
dans les séries nous sommes en plein
dans le chacun pour soi pour las vegas
les chérit les quatre finalistes sont
gilles verdez enora malagré matthieu
delormeau et valérie benaïm
[Applaudissements]
il ya un aquarium il ya de l'eau le
premier qui arrive à boire toute l'eau
de l'aquarium à las vegas à n'est pas le
jeu inverse grâce à la poussée
d'archimède le vert oui un if l'homme il
flotte
oui bah oui vous allez devoir mettre des
jetons dans le vert le premier qui fera
couler le vert et éliminer l'eau restera
3 allez on y va on y va pour l'instant
ça va faire plus d'un tour l'audition
chez an dernier j'aime faire n'est pas
tout la main oui non c'est pas nous ont
pas les riches il est bon parfois c'est
moi mais moi c'est bon je m'attendais
voulais pas le maître étonnez-vous je
vais me faire un voire franchement ça
n'a rien à voir mais si j'ai un visa de
ouf et août à paris
[Applaudissements]
il ya une cible ici vienneau déchirent
leur idéal si blanc seing elia il ya des
fléchettes vous avez trois frichet
tchèque celui qui fera le meilleur score
partira à las vegas mais je veux
rajouter une règle on va faire que deux
fléchettes et joy et jade masse vont
jouer
[Applaudissements]
oh là là c'est pas nous c'est un nul il
est pas nul
il ya 6 et 8 6 contre sexe jusqu'à 15 il
ya marqué las vegas est ce que quelqu'un
peut bien cacher jeanne mas il ya quand
même y'a un mec gaillard mecs derrière
qui donne la règle osaka en tout honneur
d'accord que la quoi qu'il arrive si
tout cela se faisait gagner à part il
nous est apparu à la maison à part si
vous faites un safari gate égalité jeu
las vegas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]